>> Sandra: THE BORDER CRISIS
PROVED TO BE A TOP OF BORDER
ISSUE IN A SPECIAL TEXAS
ELECTION.
>> John: MAYRA FLORES TURNED A
SEAT RED IN ALMOST A DECADE.
SOME ANALYSTS SAY IT COULD BE A
WAVE THIS FALL.
>> THANK FOR HAVING ME.
>> Sandra: WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE
YOUR WIN MEANS FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN NOVEMBER?
>> WELL, IT MEANS HONESTLY
EVERYTHING.
IN SOUTH TEXAS WE HAVE BEEN
TAKEN FOR GRANTED FOR A LONG
TIME AND WE SHOWED THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY THEY DO NOT OWN OUR VOTE,
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET TO WORK,
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
INVESTED IN SOUTH TEXAS AND
THAT'S WHY WE WERE ABLE TO, YOU
KNOW, SPREAD THE MESSAGE ACROSS
OUR DISTRICT THAT WE ARE PRO
GOD, PRO LIFE, PRO FAMILY, ABOUT
HARD WORK, WE ARE THE PARTY
FIGHTING FOR THE EVERYDAY
AMERICAN AND I'M SO PROUD TO BE
THE FIRST REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN THAT WAS BORN IN
MEXICO AND BEING A VOICE FOR ALL
HISPANICS, NOT ONLY IN TEXAS
DISTRICT 34 BUT THE COUNTRY AS
WELL.
>> John: YOU COME FROM A FA AMLY
OF DEMOCRATIC VOTERS, I BELIEVE
YOU VOTED FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA IN
2008.
AND WHEN YOU TAKE A RECENT
LOOKING AT POLLING ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S RATING WITH LATINO
VOTERS, HE IS IN DIRE STRAITS,
24% SUPPORT AMONG HISPANICS.
IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEAVING
YOU OR ARE YOU LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
ABANDONED THE HISPANIC
COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE FOCUSED ON WHITE
LIBERAL.
THEY ARE NOT FOCUSED ON THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
THEY COULD CARE LESS AND THEY
ARE NOT REPRESENTING OUR VALUES.
WE ARE ABOUT FAITH, FAMILY AND
HARD WORK AND THAT'S THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IN SOUTH TEXAS, I'M FIGHTING FOR
THE CONSERVATIVE VALUES THAT WE
WERE INSTILLED AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE FIGHTING
FOR THOSE VALUES AND LOOK, I'M
NOT LOYAL TO A PARTY.
I'LL SAY IT OVER AND OVER, MY
LOYALTY IS WITH GOD, MY FAMILY
AND WITH MY COMMUNITY AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME TO PUT
TEXAS DISTRICT 34 FIRST.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A VOICE HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
NO ONE REALLY CARED WHAT WE HAD
TO SAY AND NOW PEOPLE DO CARE
ABOUT THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY,
NOW PEOPLE ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
THE VOICE OF TEXAS DISTRICT 34,
I'M PROUD AND HUMBLED TO BE
REPRESENTING ALL TEXAS DISTRICT
34 AND HISPANIC COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
>> Sandra: AND ATTENTION YOU ARE
RECEIVING, PART IS BECAUSE YOUR
HUSBAND IS A BORDER PATROL EIGHT
AND OBVIOUSLY A CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAT HAS TO BE
DEALT WITH.
WHAT IS THE MESSAGE YOU ARE
BRINGING TO WASHINGTON?
WHAT IS YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND MAKE THE
SITUATION BETTER AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON LEGAL IMMIGRATION
AND IMPROVING THE PROCESS HOW WE
CAN MAKE IT MORE, YOU KNOW,
FASTER, AFFORDABLE FOR THE GOOD
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME HERE
FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I'LL NEVER UNDERSTAND WHY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS TO
ENCOURAGE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
KNOWING THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
ABUSE AND KNOWING CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO BE PUT INTO CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING, IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WE REALLY CARE
ABOUT CHILDREN.
LET ME TELL YOU, NO MATTER WHERE
CHILDREN ARE FROM, THEY ARE
INNOCENT AND WE NEED TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND IF WE CARE ABOUT
CHILDREN WE WOULD FOCUS ON
BORDER SECURITY, TO KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE AND WOMEN ALSO
WOULD NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH SO
MUCH ABUSE.
LET'S ALLOW THEM TO COME HERE TO
THIS COUNTRY LEGALLY, BUT LET'S
IMPROVE THE PROCESS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY DOESN'T CARE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH SUCH
ABUSE.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
>> John: LET'S LOOK TOWARD
NOVEMBER IF WE COULD, MAYRA, YOU
WILL RUN AGAINST THE CURRENT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE 15TH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT AND IS
MOVING OVER TO WHAT WILL BE THE
NEWLY INSTALLED 34TH REDRAWN
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
SOME FOLKS SAY YOUR RACE IS
GOING TO BE A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT IN NOVEMBER.
>> IT'S A LOT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
VINCENTE.
HE THOUGHT JUMPING INTO 34 WOULD
BE AN EASIER WIN, IT'S NOT.
IT'S GOING TO BE THE TOUGHEST
FIGHT HE'S EVER FOUGHT AND HE
THINKS HE'S A BETTER
REPRESENTATIVE BECAUSE HE WAS
BORN IN TEXAS AND I WAS BORN IN
MEXICO AND I HAVE A MESSAGE TO
HIM THAT EVEN THOUGH I WAS BORN
IN MEXICO, I LOVE THIS COUNTRY
VERY MUCH, AND I'M REPRESENTING
DISTRICT 34 AND I WANT TO SEE
THE DISTRICT 34 BLOSSOM.
>> John: THE POINT I WAS GETTING
TO THERE, THE NEWLY REDRAWN
BORDERS WILL BE IN EFFECT THE
NOVEMBER 8TH ELECTION, BUT
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO BE BETTER
PICKING VIABLE CANDIDATES THAN
IN THE PAST WHEN IT COMES TO
LATINAS AND LATINOS.
WE WILL REQUEST VEGA WHO WON THE
PRIMARY IN THE 7TH CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN VIRGINIA AND
EXPECTED SHE WILL LIKELY RUN A
VERY STRONG RACE AGAINST ABIGAIL
SPANBERGER IN NOVEMBER.
SO, DOES THIS REPRESENT A REAL
INVESTMENT ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY GETTING GOOD LATINO AND
LATINA CANDIDATES TO RUN IN THE
GENERAL ELECTIONS AND SPECIAL
ELECTIONS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE THEIR BEST INVESTMENT AND
NO MATTER WHAT THE LINES ARE,
SOUTH TEXAS IS VERY
CONSERVATIVE.
AGAIN, WE ARE CONSECUTIVE BY
NATURE.
FAITH, FAMILY, AND HARD WORK.
THAT'S NOT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I'M FIGHTING FOR THOSE VALUES
AND WE NEED THAT TYPE OF
REPRESENTATION IN WASHINGTON.
>> Sandra: THAT BEING SAID,
YOU'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
I WONDER HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT ALL
THAT ATTENTION ELON MUSK AND
OTHERS FIRST TIME I EVER VOTED
REPUBLICAN, HOW DOES IT FEEL TO
GET ALL THIS ATTENTION?
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT SAYS ABOUT
THE STATE OF YOUR PARTY?
>> I'M SO GRATEFUL TO HIM AND
ALSO SPACEX FOR EVERYTHING THAT
THEY ARE DOING FOR SOUTH TEXAS
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY
ARE GIVING TO THE PEOPLE IN
TEXAS DISTRICT 34.
IT'S BECAUSE OF HIM THAT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF JOBS
WERE CREATED IN OUR DISTRICT AND
I'M FOREVER GRATEFUL TO HIM AND
EVERYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO COME
TO SOUTH TEXAS.
WE ARE THE MOST HARD WORKING
PEOPLE, SO I INVITE PEOPLE TO
COME TO SOUTH TEXAS AND INVEST
IN SOUTH TEXAS BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT ONLY AMAZING PEOPLE, ALL
ABOUT FAITH AND FAMILY, BUT ALSO
THE MOST HARD WORKING.
>> John: FINAL QUESTION FOR YOU,
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS, SOME OF YOUR
CRITICS HAVE POINTED OUT A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN YOU WERE
THE CHAIR WOMAN FOR THE HISPANIC
OUTREACH OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
FOR HIDALGO COUNTY, YOU PUT A
COUPLE SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS THAT
INCLUDED # FOR QANON.
>> IT WAS A #, AND MY POST WAS
AGAINST IT.
I HAVE NEVER SUPPORTED ANY OF
THOSE CONSPIRACIES AND NONE OF
THIS NONSENSE.
>> John: SO WHY INCLUDE IT?
>> WASHINGTON WANTS US TO FOCUS
ON NONSENSE, I'M FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER IN MY
DISTRICT AND RIGHT NOW, INCREASE
OF GAS, FOOD, AND HEALTHCARE.
>> Sandra: WHY WAS IT INCLUDED
IN THE TWEETS?
ACCOUNT OBVIOUSLY MANAGED BY
YOU.
>> STAY FOCUS ON THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER.
>> John: WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER, ANYBODY THAT
WATCHES FOX NEWS WOULD TELL YOU
THAT.
WE ARE JUST WONDERING WHAT YOU
SAY TO THE CRITICS WHO POINT TO
THAT AND CURIOUS WHY YOU WOULD
HAVE INCLUDED THOSE IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
>> I'VE SAID IT OVER AND OVER,
NEVER SUPPORTED ANY OF THOSE
CONSPIRACIES.
AGAIN, STAY FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BORDER CRISIS AND OF COURSE THE
ECONOMY.
>> John: FAIR ENOUGH.
GOOD TO TALK TO YOU.
CONGRESSWOMAN MAYRA FLORES FROM
THE GREAT STA